on this episode I knew the show
[Music]
this is
Carrie B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is the askgaryvee
show episode 101 so yeah yeah we're
gonna we're gonna keep doing it you know
you know it's funny I had like hardcore
hardcore fans I appreciate thank you so
much that literally emailed me the two
episodes all time on Wine Library TV
where I flirted about retiring so you
know old tricks are hard to drop
sometimes so thank you so much for
everybody came out for episode 100 it
was epic thank you to the team thank you
guys so much
57 minutes of edited magic if you have
not watched episode 100 it is a huge
mistake
d-roc link it up India let's get into a
show ladee asks why would people sell
clothes on Instagram when people can
just go to the actual store to get what
you're selling this is gonna be so fun
this new format is gonna be so fun all
right one more time
what's the name I'm so pumped we came up
with this lot a lot a lot a great
question listen Lottie the reason this
is happening is because marketers ruin
everything
anytime a lot of people pay attention to
something and that's what's happening on
Instagram it evolves right it started
off as artistic photographers doing
their thing then people started moving
and kind of putting their selfies and
their lives on there started becoming
the new Facebook and so once there's
that much attention business business
people like myself and others can't help
it but go in there and try to start
selling things to others it's just the
way it is now the nice thing about
Instagram though is is that it's not
gonna pop up in your feed you've got to
follow them so clearly you followed this
person or your friend followed this
person if they showed it to them I'm not
sure how you saw somebody selling there
but you're more than welcome to unfollow
so you know you can take your time and
go on Twitter and complain about it
which I love I love the sass but
the fact that matter is the quick
unfollow will keep you away from and
unlike other platforms I expect
Instagram to go that route because
that's how you make money but that's the
reason the reason is because people are
paying attention and where people are
paying attention is an opportunity to
sell just like listening to the radio
just like watching TV just like turning
the pages in a newspaper if you're
paying attention just like going to
internet websites with banners if
someone's paying attention someone is
trying to sell Ryan Andrew says
marketing to the next generation through
Facebook is on par with ads in the
yellow pages
anyone disagree Facebook is dead what's
next Ryan hey it's me Gary Vee I know we
don't know each other but alex is gonna
be hitting you up with a link to this i
massively disagree as a matter fact
emphatically disagree I think what's
next is people waking up and realizing
Facebook is just starting to grow I have
made the mistake many times in my career
of the same thing that you're saying on
Twitter which was I said in 2003 hey
SCM Google AdWords is dead what's next
while Google was just starting Facebook
dark posts the ability to reach out to
everybody don't forget you know no more
yellow pages is more like Google search
you're going there to find something
Facebook's coming to you you're in a
feed and you're seeing it no more the
right side of a desktop website nobody I
don't even know what this is this is
like this is like an artifact right and
so like the fact I matter is no more on
the right side of a website it's coming
in your feed and if you know how to
target and you know how to create
content properly you win and so I would
say I I disagree and number two what's
next is people actually understanding
what's really happening in facebook like
do it right on spot I think I think
there's you know well since we don't
edit anymore Steve this black and white
version of it is that clear Lake's gonna
explain what we're doing which is you
know cats out a bag now that Steve
ruined it I'm planning on going a little
bit of run here of like looking for
questions on Twitter this is gonna be a
lot of fun and I
promise I'll mix in your questions
because I appreciate you the most but
we're gonna have a little bit fun here
and it's also gonna allow me to you know
round out the questions because the
vaynernation
you know much like me we get into ruts
we're asking similar questions you know
let's see what comes up next India
follow my cue here India ask the weird
and funny question yes go ahead
Jeana asks wait how does one deactivate
Twitter
hey Jeana it's Gary
it's really easy to be activate Twitter
on your phone
it's called deleting the app itself hope
it works for you Izzy says people ruined
the artistic intention of Instagram like
now people try to sell a fridge on it
delivered that yeah I mean this is
clearly the theme of the show oh by the
way real quick shout out to Scott this
is an incredible personal wine box let's
give them personal wine boxes comm shout
out I love how people are hacking me for
free promotion I feel like a sucker
right now but like I do love and Chris
this is this is insane I mean Chris
screen this is just absolutely insane
show MUP dirac this is unbelievable I
mean there's there's a ton know about
this yeah listen I just said it earlier
people are ruining Instagram people
trying to sell their fridges people
trying to sell clothes there was one I
saw why are people trying to sell food
on Instagram but I didn't think I could
stop from laughing through that question
from India the bottom line is attention
attention attention that's
value prop is you know the reason I
picked both those questions is to the
Matic size this episode I know what that
means sorry grammar police but the theme
of this show yes you Steve
the theme of this show is very simple
which is Instagram has the attention
people are going to sell on it
get over it that's what's always gonna
happen and so the reason people trying
to sell you a fridge on Instagram is the
same reason you asked the question on
Twitter which means it caught your
attention whereas if they tried to sell
their fridge on Twitter I'm not sure it
would have get it Kwan's kitchen asks
how many of you guys use Pinterest we're
just finding our feet on it what would
you like to see from Kwan's kitchen
Kwan's kitchen big shout-out to you guys
I love the businesses that are going
into the trenches and actually asking
their users what they want to see my
friends all you small businesses out
there all you solo entrepreneurs Kwan's
kitchen a Chinese restaurant in Scotland
big ups here from USA bless you from USA
America I'm very proud of that execution
because you're gonna get insight and see
what happens you know somebody on the
social media team or maybe the owner of
clown sketch it's like hey let me put
this out there and sure enough some
crazy dude decides to pick it up and put
on the show where a lot of people gonna
see it great exposure
all my Scotland is that I'm triple
confirming this yeah so all my Scottish
friends please if you're watching the
askgaryvee show
go visit Kwan's give them some DAP don't
you agree Steve only agree good you know
this is a great question I think
Pinterest is an incredibly important
platform
I think Pinterest am I too close to a
rock what do you sad about you hit your
stomach with the bar and that's why you
had that mood I got it Kwan's Pinterest
my friends vaynernation everyone who's
listening to this Kwan's kitchen they're
not quite succeed redirects dis
recomment Pinterest Pinterest is the new
social network for search right there
was a social network it's a search
engine Pinterest is a search engine
people are searching on there and
they're getting visual search and I see
you shaking your head get in here get in
here get over here come over here and
give me a hug
I was sitting the court I saw you in the
corner of my eye right you don't get as
much air time as everyone why don't you
tell what's the wheel down because I
don't like when people aren't taller to
me I'm already tired it's fine but I'm
really short to tell them tell the manor
nation what you do here the designer for
Gary yeah
why were you shaking your head so
emphatically what is your behavior on
Pinterest I'm a huge interest lover but
designing a lot of your stuff on
Pinterest people search for it and yeah
it seems pretty important all right that
was terrible the bottom line is there
are going to be no ask Andrew show any
design I get it but I'm tremendous on
the spot um well I am Steve okay well
thank you um interesting searching yeah
I mean look I mean the dirac over here
it's a search engine it's a search
engine it's visual search we become all
more visual there's a real visual
revolution and I actually think Google
should be shaking in their pants around
what's going on in Pinterest
I think pictures is a tremendous ad
product so I would say put out a lot of
stuff and put out a lot of stuff of your
dishes and your meals but don't make
them stock photos get them out there I
would make infographics I would make an
infographic of the perfect Chinese food
dinner where it's like step one do this
step to like drink water step three try
this drink step four you know like make
it fun step four like talk to your
friends Step five play with the
fortunately a really fun piece of
content that I could see going
tremendously well for you I think
infographics over-index I think you know
photos of the here's a incredible thing
if you have a physical location what
about photos of the street that you're
on it that's cool just take a nice photo
the street that you're on what about you
taking the lead and taking photos of the
fellow business owners around you
there's a lot of creative things act
like a media company put out content
that's interesting
put a content that's valuable to people
not in your best interest not your menu
not your store it can't be all about you
it needs to be all about what can they
possibly want Pinter's is growing in the
mail demo because it's just valuable
it's converting into a hardcore search
engine it's going to be an enormous
big deal I'm all-in on Pinterest I
invested at vayner/rse in the last round
Pinterest and an eleven billion dollar
valuation that I think is underpriced
massively hi Gary so I heard to be the
best you have to learn from the best so
I'm gonna be a little bit cheeky here
and ask how do I get a job working for
you a great question and and it happens
all the time and the reason I want to
take this is as we you know obviously
after episode one hundred-eyed 12 to 15
people by the way that I'm his film
broke I had 12 to 15 people at the show
asked me like hey I want to work for you
I'm always flattered by that I get
hundreds of emails a month and I you
know and I think it comes down to there
is no right answer there's plenty of
people that have gotten here by pounding
me 15 times and then eventually I get
them an interview but I think that's
going like Oh 447 so that's like an
interesting insight to people that pound
me 47 times there's people that just
went through the system and just applied
and vaynermedia so website has tons of
job openings I think the one move that a
lot of people haven't done other than
maybe d-roc that I can think of and
paper that's a really interesting I
wasn't gonna give this answer I was
gonna go in different directions
Kevin Rose founder of Digg internet
personality extraordinaire great friend
did something super smart years ago he
wanted to get into square he thought was
gonna be a big company and Jack didn't
let him in Jack had his homies that came
in so Kevin went out and made a video
that was enormous ly interesting with
great insights and things around Square
and it was so viral and it was so strong
that that gave him the ability to invest
in square at a very early stage where
now it's worth billions on paper and
I've always been fascinated by that
d-roc think about how many times did you
reach out to do a video for me one was
it lucky like that three Saudi rock
three times reached out and asked to do
a video paid forward first made a piece
of content showed me his skills and then
you know obviously the rest is history
now he's like I mean I don't know if you
guys are paying attention but like he's
got a bigger fan base than I do
so you know look look Chris Green now
could like I
Chris Green to make Lego structures for
clients of vaynermedia
I'm not even joking he's doing his own
thing but if Chris set me up and said I
want to make Lego like structures for
campaigns at vaynermedia I would hire
him here it is I see it
I mean India's hair is long like the
Starbucks thing like Stefan's Brooklyn
hat like the detail is insanity here I
mean just crazy so so you know you know
that I I think doing something first is
a real hack so give that some thought
question of the day what would you like
to see happen over the next 100 episodes
of the askgaryvee show and and I'm
really gonna read all these it's
Memorial Day weekend
give me your kind of two to three
bullets on the first hundred episodes
experience the value prop the it became
repetitive it's better than ever like
give me concepts thoughts you're three
bullets on the first 100 episodes thank
you for being part of this ride I'm
clearly enjoying it I'm projecting at
least 100 more episodes you keep asking
questions I'll clearly keep answering
them
I'll really think that night everybody
sorry in there do you want to work with
me
[Music]